[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24 y
ya nos acompaña en nuestra mesa de
trabajo más Romero sala mar bienvenida
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a
empezar con lo que parecen buenas
noticias sobre una enfermedad Pues que
la comentamos también la semana pasada
hablamos del Alzheimer que podría haber
un nuevo fármaco disponible Mar buenos
días Así es una noticia dada por dos
farmacéuticas que pues juntas provocaron
hicieron este este fármaco no es la
farmacéutica Easy y violín una es
japonesa la otra estadounidense y el
gran titular digamos de la noticia es
que parece retrasar el deterioro
cognitivo provocado por el alzheimer en
al menos un
27%, no es una cifra gigante pero
definitivamente es muy significativo en
una enfermedad Como era Alzheimer de la
que estamos hablando este medicamento se
llama lecanemab y no está exento tampoco
de efectos secundarios que explicamos
aquí el grupo de los que tomó el
medicamento versus del grupo que tomó
placebo en los que sí tomaron el
medicamento 10 puntos porcentuales más
de inflamación del cerebro y ocho puntos
porcentuales más de microhemorragias
entonces sin embargo es importante decir
que de estos lo que se tradujo en
síntomas no en molestias sentidas por
los pacientes fueron menos del 3%,
entonces bueno Parece que son efectos
secundarios relativamente tolerables O
al menos que hacen que la medicina sea
segura o ese balance sea positivo no
importante como sabe también ya sabes
que me gusta revisar Cómo se ha hecho el
estudio la muestra etcétera no tenemos
un estudio con casi 1800 participantes
es una muestra muy grande durante se les
dice un seguimiento Durante un año y
medio aproximadamente de hecho es
importante decir que el estudio clínico
sigue para ver cómo siguen pues
desarrollandose explorando exacto no
este este este tratamiento pero bueno
como es un estudio en etapa 3 es el
último la última etapa de los estudios
Hay bastante optimismo y de hecho
también en los mercados para ahí si veo
bien que les ha ido muy bien en el día
de hoy con esta noticia Cómo funcionaría
este nuevo este nuevo medicamento cómo
funciona Mejor dicho porque ya se está
probando sí Exacto se inyecta un
anticuerpo diseñado para combatir uno de
los que se considera que es el principal
causante del Alzheimer que es en los que
se llama Beta amiloides es una proteína
una cadena de aminoácidos que pues
cumple varias funciones en el cerebro
pero que con el paso del tiempo y con la
edad avanzada se acumula a veces
generando una placa que se asocia con el
alzheimer y muchos también creen que
hasta luego llega a provocar en este
caso este medicamento se inyecta cada
dos semanas Si no recuerdo mal y la
verdad es que la gran mayoría de
tratamientos que se han intentado contra
el alzheimer siguen esta misma filosofía
no atacar esta placa que se genera en el
cerebro de estos betas amiloides sin
embargo es muy importante decir que hay
una cierta controversia hay dudas
alrededor de este tipo de si realmente
los medicamentos que ataquen a estas
proteínas funcionan realmente en una
enfermedad tan multicausal como es el
alzheimer si vale la pena también la
cantidad de dinero que dedica Pues a
financiar estos medicamentos que sonó
muy caros no también estas dos
farmacéuticas Tenían un medicamento muy
parecido anterior a este que pues
presentaron hoy que también había habido
mucha controversia porque se argumentaba
que tener buenos pues efectos en limpiar
esta placa cerebral no se traducía en
buenos efectos a la hora de retrasar el
deterioro cognitivo sin embargo los
directores ejecutivos de las
farmacéuticas han insistido en que los
resultados de este estudio que se
publicó el día de hoy finalmente dan
este espaldarazo definitivo a que estas
terapias contra pues estas proteínas las
betamiloides sí funcionan escuchémoslo
el estudio muestra que eliminar el
exceso de beta amiloide en el cerebro se
asocia con una desaceleración de la
enfermedad en los pacientes en etapas
tempranas eisai cree que estos hallazgos
crearán Nuevos Horizontes en el
diagnóstico y tratamiento del Alzheimer
a la vez que activará más Innovación
para nuevas opciones de tratamiento sin
duda una buena noticia una esperanza en
esta enfermedad con unas consecuencias
tan tristes también la esperanza
prudente déjame apuntar una esperanza
siempre prudencia pero pues ahí hay una
Lucecita al final Déjame ser optimista
pasamos a otro tema el impacto del 19 en
el personal médico de nuestro continente
mar sí Raúl en este caso vamos ya del
lado un poco más oscuro de las noticias
de salud es un informe masivo publicado
por la organización Panamericana de la
salud sobre el impacto que ha tenido el
cómic 19 en todo el continente americano
hay muchísimos datos hay perfiles por
países pero nosotros nos vamos a centrar
en un aspecto muy concreto y es el
impacto que ha tenido la pandemia sobre
el personal médico y de la salud en el
continente americano no las cifras
recopiladas tenemos que al más de casi 2
millones 400 a 1000 médicos o personal
trabajadores de la salud en general sean
contagiado de covid desde el inicio de
la pandemia Se supone casi el 15%, El
16% perdón del total del personal médico
americano y en el caso de las muertes
por Kobe 19 se han registrado más de
13.000 que estén confirmadas sin embargo
la OMS Calcula que las muertes de
personal médico por Kobe 19 raíz de la
pandemia Podrían haber llegado a rondar
las 60.000 desde que empezó la crisis
sanitaria pero es que además de las
cifras que más dice este informe también
destaca que hay un déficit crónico de
personal de la salud en el continente
americano y también en todo el mundo de
hecho se estima que en todo el mundo
faltan a 15 millones de trabajadores de
la salud para pues poder cumplir con los
objetivos de buena atención que
necesitan los pacientes de nuestras
sociedades también destaca que sí en el
continente americano en toda nuestra
región 7 de cada diez personas que
trabajan en el ámbito de la salud son
mujeres que por lo tanto son las mujeres
las que han sentido una carga
desproporcional tanto en los casos de
covid y tienen las muertes por Kobe 19
como en todos los otros impactos que
también ha tenido la pandemia hablamos
por ejemplo de la Salud Mental Porque
además en el caso de las mujeres no solo
es esta sobrecarga laboral sino también
se sumó toda la sobrecarga que hubo en
los hogares Durante los momentos de
cuarentena mar y terminamos con una
mención al día por la lucha por el
aborto legal y seguro así ya se
conmemora este 28 de septiembre y yo
quería explicar que la Organización
Mundial de la Salud defiende desde
siempre que lo que hace falta es
despenalizar el aborto levantar las
restricciones que pesan legales para la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
vamos a remitirnos algunas de las cifras
que da la también la Organización
Mundial de la Salud la mitad casi la
mitad de todos los abortos que se
producen en el mundo son inseguros es un
problema de salud pública y de derechos
humanos de dimensiones considerables
casi 40.000 muertes se deben a estos las
interrupciones pues voluntarias del
embarazo que se dan en entornos ina
seguros además importante decir que
todas estas muertes todas estas 40.000
muertes que se dan en todo el mundo Son
evitables son muertes que se podrían
evitar si este procedimiento se da de
forma segura además estás casi 40.000
muertes suponen el 10% aproximadamente
de todas las muertes maternas en el
mundo no la Organización Mundial de la
Salud seguimos con sus lineamientos no
solo recomienda la despenalización total
del aborto sino también recomienda o
dice que no se deberían dar esos
periodos de reflexión que muchos países
obligan a las mujeres y a las personas
que quieren aportar a tener esos tres
días a veces de reflexión recomiendan
que no se den y también intentan decir
que la decisión no dependa de nadie más
que dependa únicamente de la mujer o de
la persona que quiera abortar también lo
decimos Porque muchos países que por
ejemplo pues en Casos requieren la
autorización de las madres o de las
otras personas que estén implicadas la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
recomienda que no que la decisión sea
únicamente de la mujer que decide
abortar como tiene que ser mal
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información mañana Por supuesto más
salud gracias